[Music]
hey babe how are you sir how you doing
I'm doing good I wanted to wear the
brand new sneakers that I bought which
are light blue Nike blazers mid-range in
honor of Our Guest Ashley Gavin who's a
lesbian thank you and you were the
official two of my P
Eep Midway
mid Rock so much very specific yeah I
would imagine mine is more yeah yours
are a little more like oh is that a
little boy in the skate park or is that
a grown woman
that's what I would say my look is you
ever pick a pair of these Reebok uh 80
what are they called c88
I'm doing some shoe shopping so I I
watched it on New Balances
you strike us you strike me as you're
one of those she's cool she's got the
new fashion thank you so [__] much I
try so hard yeah
you read baggy shirts you read as
fashionable to me this is a great day
yeah this is the first conversation I've
had today yes I haven't even eaten
anything you were listening to the wrong
podcast you listen to Christy chaos
that's why you're intermittent fasting
but here at hey babe we eat like gavones
what a great start I'm so happy thank
you you're getting the vibe you're
listening to chaos to prepare for this
to get a sense of it yeah yeah but
you're immediately getting the vibe
because we're one minute and we're
talking fashion yeah we're talking
fashion we're talking glasses which Sal
you haven't seen these glasses no so
here's a couple things first of all you
have you had those and you lost them yes
and then you and then you you you didn't
find them you purchased the new page I
repurchased a new pair for full price
I've done that so many times with
sunglasses it's embarrassing right it's
it's like so humiliating because you
have one pair of sunglasses and you're
like I spent fifteen hundred dollars on
this and then one pair of sunglasses
because I bought them eight times but
here's the thing I lost the glasses and
the case they come in a huge case in
that case well they need we need a huge
case
they fell out of my pocket as I it must
have even as I sat in my car I forgot
they were in my pocket and they fell out
and then I shut the door and took off
and then I realized an hour later don't
okay okay so this happens with glasses
it happens with umbrellas it even
happens you're able to be like whatever
happened to that shirt right
don't you want to know and will never
know the second life that those the
first pair of glasses is that's a Toy
Story movie for sure it is right that
has to be
Story movie like where all the second
the second yeah and I bet you we're part
of those stories even fine you ever find
something you ever find a pair of glass
or like you're part of that story for
somebody else but I wonder who's wearing
those glasses I have such a funny story
about a lost sweatshirt I haven't told
the story I grew up here in New York
City and I had a sweatshirt from camp
and it had my name embroidered on it
because me and all my friends we went to
camp and we had such a good summer and
so we made a inside joke sweatshirt are
kids still doing that like inside joke
sweatshirts
custom ink came out when I was in high
school yeah so that was a bones to pick
with custom ink okay yeah but continue
look at this I lost everything as a
child because I I have trauma I was one
of those kids that just lost
not a gaming problem no no just like no
no not as a kid I was a 15 year old and
I bet the house
I lost everything in Atlantic City when
I was 14. no possible I mean maybe I
lost my sweatshirt I was devastated
because it was my all my best friends
had the sweatshirt I didn't know that
sweatshirt right three weeks later I'm
walking by like a bodega outside of the
bodega homeless man is sitting on a
crate the crate is lined with my
sweatshirt I'm reading line like oh
sitting on it
no and I remember looking at the
sweatshirt and thinking how badly dude
um I don't remember how much I gave him
but I just gave him whatever I had and I
got the sweatshirt how old were you I
was 15 years
a homeless man's ass I I did was sitting
on that sweatshirt and you paid money to
get it back all the washing in the world
I know can't wash it I know I put bleach
you still don't have that sweatshirt no
I lost it again I put bleach in with the
with the wash and then it turned the
whole thing like pinkish so mine was
ended up being different I have so many
questions sweatshirt now that you have a
successful podcast you become a
successful comedian I say You remake
that sweatshirt
you sell that as merch yeah sell that as
merch wait wait what was the inside joke
is this people I never think like that
what was the inside joke that was on it
we uh we had like um like a like oh God
this is so like no this is the place
so we were like we went on this trip and
we were the 20th trip in 2003 it's not
even a joke it was just like so we did
like a double x03 thing for that and
then obviously
yeah with the camp okay you're not like
talking about acid or something no no no
no no we did not I'm I'm again I did not
lose the house right I was not on acid
as a 15 year old wait why was there
because there was two x's and not like
it was it was 20. it was the 20th like
yeah you said there was like a sexual
yeah and you have double X and you're 15
and it's not even like a bid it's just
like you know it's just like so the
sweatshirt was two xx3 yeah it was XX uh
apostrophe 03 because it was 2000 that
was the 20th camping trip you took yeah
it was like the 20th of this like Camp
yeah annually not that I had done it oh
my god oh gotcha I didn't do it in the
womb but this is so stupid to explain
the bigger overarching theme is that a
homeless man had my sweater and I was a
big enough douchebag to take it back and
I think I probably gave him a twenty
dollars
first of all did you approach him before
money did you just say excuse me you're
sitting on mine I think I just felt so
guilty because I had you know so much
more than you lose it no I probably did
you did you take it off
or something all right okay I probably
was inside
I was having a hot fun are you going
through menopause at 13 and you took it
off again I lost the house
ever again what is 2x bad
2x isn't great what is 2x double XL no
no no no no but as far as it triple x
triple X means sex I don't know what
double X oh triple okay I understand
what you're saying
triple X is like hardcore what I would
think 2x might mean
fellatio
yeah it goes from R to Triple X NC 17.
so what's what's in between NC 17 and
triple I think triple X is just like
colloquial okay right because there's x
rated there's definitely x-rated right
can I just say something while we're
talking about this I just want to say
something that I discovered at um I I
was in uh shout out to the people that
came out to Buffalo Ithaca and Albany
great time and in the hotel I kind of
tried to reinvent myself a little bit
with the porn I watch and rather than
going on PornHub mindlessly we didn't do
the rental no what I did was I went on
Reddit I went on Reddit and there was
some great there was some great tips
some great memes and and kind of videos
to go on on uh on Reddit uh let me see
here we go we got
um Reddit one of the ones I found that
I'll pass along is uh um
wait you watch pornography [__] hungry
[__] was good okay
um black chicks white dicks I really
enjoyed uh
NSFW is that a black chick with a white
dick literally they say just as it was
being in the room when you buy a
strap-on get it the same tone as your
body right okay don't don't do what you
just described that's good advice well I
mean but Tim's riding they're coming out
in a variety of colors sure sure and
maybe like purple yellow orange yes yes
that's okay fine that's fine okay but I
think what because we've we as a society
now kind of less is less is more rather
than watching what I used to do is watch
a whole 25 minute scene get to know the
players get to know the characters where
time is money you get a nice you go on
Reddit you go to some of these W memes
and and you really get in nice 10 to 15
seconds what you came for yeah and the
thing with Reddit though is it's their
surprises because you put in you know
the search engine and they that doesn't
that can mean anything so it could be
you know
okay I I just like read it as people are
so mean you know they say really mean
things about people yes I know I saw one
of the one of the things that one of the
porn scenes I watched one of the
comments was she's okay but has weird
nipples why would
I would why
it's literally deep throating a car what
are
just to say that that's like when I when
I see Amazon reviews oh and you go to
Amazon and there's questions for the
product yeah and someone will be like
does you know does this work with this
adapter and then people will log on to
the Amazon account and answer this
question and be like I'm not sure yeah
that's what they write back they log on
they're like I'm not sure bought it for
my wife the question continues yeah yeah
why are you why are you on here
answering questions I got a scooter I
got a scooter for my daughter's birthday
and the video like that shows you how to
use the scooter on Amazon was like you
know a a woman and her daughter in
America but she had a Russian accent and
one of the comments was are we really
supporting Russia with what they're
doing to Ukraine I'm like we're talking
about scooter you're a seven-year-old on
Amazon please yeah people are crazy
people are I'm trying to write a joke
about this not this many people should
be able to read and write so many people
with literacy with too much access it
used to be that you had to be both
literate and you had to afford paper and
a pen and a guy on a horse yes you
needed all those things in order to
protect your opinion out into the world
I think we should it should be like an
entrance exam to get a social media
account yeah you know what I mean like
some type of testing sometimes I think
it should all be it should not be free I
think every you should it's be 20 a
month like you gotta just you can't let
everybody have it maybe but you can't be
able to speak yes you're allowed you can
have internet yeah you can't speak every
time you speak you have to put a dollar
behind it and then you're like is it is
does it mean that much to me right to
say I'm not sure right or weird nipples
yeah I mean we've we've essentially
eliminated social media yes promotions
now I really try not to same with me
quick question before we move on yes I
don't want to move on but those were
unless I got my information wrong those
were expensive like like I used Kia
almost expensive well they they were
they were a thousand thousand bucks your
glasses yeah 2 000. oh you're the first
one you got on the Young no no first one
you pay full price and then the second
did you plug the guy's store what it's
capitalism wow what can you do and
you're forced to plug this guy's store
over and over again he knows he's yes so
you know you're losing another pair of
glasses because you're like you gotta go
down but this is what my family was
telling me let's stick like one of those
tiles on there or something that's the
thing that's what my family was telling
me they were like when I bought them
they're like you are not the kind of
person that cares about this stuff
you're going to eventually lose them
again so I said if I lose this pair I'm
done on I'm done if I lose this pair and
what I've been doing now is I've been
going one week on with them one week off
this is obviously the week on with them
but then next week I'll go the week off
to try to limit my chances of losing
them again are these are identical to
the other ones identical because what's
the brand birth control
um these are Jacques Jacques Marquez
Stanley Kubrick can I can I Stanley
Kubrick oh oh my God yeah because
Kubrick had shaped like this yes sir yep
you better believe it Planet of the Apes
glasses because I just went like this
[Laughter]
can I say this is totally off topic you
have such hairless legs he does and
great calves he does too yes both of you
have hairless legs we have the least
amount of leg hair of any podcast in New
York City
I get told that
people are like are you a swimmer I'm
like I guarantee you know if I searched
enough reddits I'd see sounds camps
would pop up somebody's opposed wow
that's the only thing I got going for me
but how do you train them I I just I
just walk around heavy set and uh just
what losers
down south down you're noticeably down
now no noticeably down I was a goalie
and they they kept okay you know but uh
going in soccer by uh hockey hockey yeah
my dad has hairless so my dad has all of
his hair he's in his uh late 70s and he
didn't go gray until about late 60s
so but he has no hair on his legs right
so I'm I signed up for it I got nice
hair hopefully I don't go gray and I
have it I don't go no bald nothing
against the ball people God bless them
but my legs that's tough yeah absolutely
like I can't my dad is you know 75 he
can't grow a beard my dad cannot grow a
beard he can't and I can't grow a beard
you can I I like I can't like our pimps
got like a beard no but like how like a
real beard how like it'll just come in
as I grows more and more it'll just come
and pouch and pouch yeah there's my dad
right there Tampa Tony who looks like
he's smoking crack cocaine in that
picture your dad looks a lot like like
little is that is that little wing I
don't know why did little Wayne come up
when you brought up it's another man
named Tampa oh oh yeah oh there's a
rapper named tampatan there's also a
woman named Tampa Tony a promiscuous
Woman real Tampa named Tony a famous a
famous no she's not famous a Roy wood
has a great story about the she's
Infamous there Tampa Tony tampatoni
all right so so they look good on you by
the way babe okay
well I go like I said today my eyes felt
puffy I'm tired I didn't feel I put on
my outfit today and I said there's not
enough bang on this yeah there's not
enough of his ass today yeah
transformative don't tell me they're not
accessories are sunglasses no these Tran
these these um transition these are
transition lenses I use them to drive
you have transition lenses no
prescription yes ma'am that is such a
commitment to the bed also that I'm not
[__] around oh so look it's kind of
dark at night no no they get dark in the
sun if when I'm driving I can see a
little bit that's why I asked you if
they were different because they I
thought they were darker last night
these are sunglasses but if you wear
them inside then uh you know they don't
that's why they're a thousand dollars
because you got the transition I got the
transition lenses yeah the frames
themselves I want to say were 700 wow
then the lenses is what cost 2023 even
glasses are transitioning
and they're much happier yeah
it's a beautiful thing what was your
first thought when you realized you
might have lost them was it did it go to
the money
no it went to it went to I I thought I
was on the road to creating this new
image this new likeness this is new 2023
me you fell off you're still alive and
then I felt like when I lost them well
now I'm gonna go back to that same old
[__] I'm going back to that same old
me and I've lost this new energy but
then I quickly found it and what I
quickly discovered was is I don't need a
pair of glasses to feel good boom boom
bap that's what I'm going to say because
what you're doing there is you're
attaching your identity to a material
item can I that's not good that's not
what Seneca or the rest of the stoics
would say right why are you what is this
new energy that you're trying to achieve
I've tried to have a glow up I tried to
force to grow up dude you've grown
yeah yeah I I I I feel like I want to
have a glow up I wanted to lose a little
bit of weight I wanted to put on some
you know get in better shape and I
wanted to start wearing turtlenecks as
someone not attracted to you at all you
are in great shape I appreciate that I
have nothing to earn from saying it to
you I appreciate that thank you very
much I think you're in great shape too
thanks
like every like pizza in between a
window of like only four hours six hours
six hours but she was saying she hasn't
eaten anything she just I do it two
hours ago out of pure laziness in the
morning but that's what happens because
you're you know thin build you you look
in shape as well and I think the people
that do that they automatically
intermittent fast but some of us have to
intentionally fast you don't have to
intentionally do it because you just
it's a you ever had to who you are yeah
I used to weigh 40 pounds more than this
when was that I'm sure that's not heavy
but I did not carry it well some girls
can be 40 pounds heavier than I am and
look just absolutely so sexy like I I
just I did not feel good how did you
what was your journey to losing 40.
honestly I just oh this is so gay I just
became a vegetarian wow and and then
that just fell off of me because I just
think it agrees with you know how
everybody has a different way of eating
and it's better genetically or whatever
and each some influencer on Instagram
will tell blood type you have yeah
exactly it just fell off of me yeah so
you still you have not eaten a piece of
meat in 10 years yeah yeah so it's just
you could you don't even do fish just
veggies all day I ate fish I gave up
fish about six years so I was
pescetarian and then I gave up fish
about six years ago but I'm going to
Japan with my girlfriend and so I was
like oh I'm gonna accidentally eat fish
because no no there's not a lot of
vegetarians there so I took I I'm trying
to I took a bite of fish like three
weeks ago it made me violently did it
really it did not my body was like what
the [__] like you started puking and
everything I got so I one bite of fish I
couldn't sleep for two hours because of
the indigestion wow whoa so wait so so
like what's a typical meal like what you
haven't eaten yet what are you gonna eat
today what's it typical give me an
answer Gavin vegetables oh my God this
is so annoying no it's not I I'll
probably have a smoothie okay you'll get
a smoothie maybe put some protein in it
some protein in there yeah that was
gonna be my first question yeah I'll do
eggs sometimes okay morning that's
another thing I'll eat and then I don't
know I I do a lot of Trader Joe's like
just frozen meals like dumplings or the
Indians salads I'll do like I'll do like
a sweet green salad how's your blood
your blood pressure your blood
cholesterol so here's this here's the
secret iron I have no my Iron's actually
fine I have this weird this I have this
weird disorder with um sickle cell
anemia it's not sickle cell anemia so
close dude it's my collagen it's called
EDS airless download I just saw them at
Brooklyn Mirage great band they were
great dealers is so hot so EDS what's it
called Miller does actually sound like
I'm like some non-binary like Barista
what's your name I'm
airless download syndrome it does sound
like one of the towns in Game of Thrones
yeah
it's connectivity so I have
um my skin is kind of stretchy okay and
uh why was I saying this because I have
low blood pressure Global okay low but
it's not a good thing you have like
dangerously low blood pressure too low
right hypermobility of joints yeah
just put your legs
oh wow how'd you do that do that do it
again I'd rather not okay yeah but but
like yeah it's like your fragility of
blood your blood vessels fragile girl so
fragile I'm just a Gumby of a human
being I I you know sometimes you do
podcasts and people interview you and
you're like I hate myself yes
I'm a vegetarian I have this stupid
disease
I would do we rip people open
it's so vulnerable I was a vegetarian I
have diseases yeah diseases what do we
got what tell them what you got I got so
much dude come on let's let's you earned
yours through bad decisions I have so
many no no no worries
I have flat feet though that the doctor
said so I have flowers I have hammer
toes because of my what's a hammer toe
they're my top my big toe crosses over
this toe like that and it starts to rub
up against the little I have one in
right now do you wear the little
separators to help you I bought them
untenable to me I bought it but it's
it's two it's a little annoying but it's
less annoying than the pain okay
I have a host of issues
yeah yeah well you got he's got sleep
apnea we both got high blood pressure
high blood pressure high cholesterol
high feet I have psoriasis
so do I but it's under control yes under
control
we've had we had severe to moderate
plaque psoriasis
on TV or for you guys yeah yes everybody
has plaque psoriasis yeah I have um I
have um I get tonsil stones tonsil
stones my girlfriend you got your
tonsils removed should I do it what do
we think how old were you when you got
them removed
were you an adult
see getting them removed as an adult is
supposedly was the most brutal yeah
don't just Ops you can do but here's the
thing I'm snoring a lot I've noticed now
sometimes it's hard for me to swallow
food do you like your wife up when you
snore
um she typically will tell me like in
the next the next morning like it was
bad last night
it's better for your marriage most
likely the reason your physician May
recommend a tonsillectomy are frequent
severe sore throats or a chronic
infection if your tonsils however if you
have infrequent uncomplicated infections
your doctor will probably just treat you
as needed so I don't get sore throats
all that much I'm good for about one to
two straps a year I'm good for about I'm
good for about
four weeks of my 52 being on amoxicillin
that's what that's typically my ratio
yeah four out of the 52 are on
amoxicillin that's not bad for various
infections yeah so so so but but I do
feel like maybe that you misspelled that
parts of the body we don't Sneed we
don't oh that was actually excellent yes
usually you still must spell every word
yes yes language is imaginary yes that's
true yes it fluctuates it changes yes
um so so yeah right go ahead go well no
I just think that I think that I'm at a
point in my life right now where you
know I I want to start getting some some
surgeries
so my lady was telling me that there's a
surgery now for sleeping because I got
to wear a mask
and I refuse to get one until like my
late 20s or something like that so but
I've been I had to take that shoot with
me on the road yeah we're comedians I I
had to travel with a machine you could
bring one less outfit exactly I swear to
God it's so tough to travel no no it's
like a weekend check a bag yeah you
don't want to bring anything
but apparently there's a there's a
surgery that you can have now they do
something because surgeries were
um intrusive because they were in the
throat and they were only 30 successful
standards that was technology that they
that they insert in you or something
like that but it's a game changer so I'm
contemplating it but I think you guys
should do it at the same time right get
both of them done at the same time so
that you don't have to take as many
weeks off from from podcasting and then
make content out of it you should lie
down together next to each other in the
hospital while you're recovering what is
she saying someone can write on a
whiteboard so you guys can communicate
with each other give us an idea to do
patreon on the patreon
what's on the patreon our sleep app
content people need us our sleep apnea
surgery patreon have you ever got any
surgeries Ashley I had my um uh sinuses
done and they fixed my deviated
September did you feel now you ran a
[__] do you understand that you were
getting that surgery you ran an
incredibly huge risk and I'm sure you
were not told about At All by your
doctors and that risk is called empty
nose syndrome do you know what I'm
talking about why do you know this
because yes yes pimp I want you to pull
up empty nose
and I almost got ens yeah so let me tell
you something what empty nose syndrome
is it's a rare complication that
develops after a turbinectomy do you
know what the turbinates are yeah so the
turbines okay so as you know so we'll
educate the people this podcast is
sponsored by Better Health tell them
about it Chris I love it so much I use
it Sal uses it therapy and mental health
are both mental health is something that
you need to get under control and
therapy helps you get that under control
all you do is fill out a brief
questionnaire you get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapists at any time for no additional
charge it really is tailored just for
you you do it from the comfort of your
own home alone don't have to go to a
therapist's office and it really is
awesome and it really makes me feel
better each and every day that's right
it's flexible and soothe your schedule
yes and if you've ever uh you know if
you've been wanting to try therapy why
not give it a try this way right uh
right yes baby all you got to do is go
to betterhealth.com hey babe and that's
better help.com hey babe and guess what
you get get tell them the discounts ten
percent off your first month ten percent
off your first month that's why I find
more balance with better help that's
better
help.com slash hey babe
I love butcher box I really do love
butcher box I just had Burgers from
there they were unbelievable I'm not
joking with you I had uh pork loin this
week for my budget box that's right I
got 14 pounds of Frozen beef and meats
and chickens and fish in my freezer so
your favorite cut is the pork loin uh no
it's not even I love the free-range
chicken okay I love the grass-fed beef
salmon the salmon they got is amazing
it's wild wild salmon yeah easily find
high quality Meat and seafood that you
can trust 100 grass-fed beef free range
organic chicken pork raisin crepe free
and wild caught Seafood you mainly raise
no antibiotics no hormones that's it uh
it's a it's a it's a service that
subscription gets delivered to your
house you could pause anytime you want
all you stop anytime you want you could
customize boxes or choose from their
boxes that's what I like here's the
thing too at butcherbox.com hey babe
when you use the code hey babe so
butcherbox.com hey babe use the code hey
babe you're gonna get two pounds of
ground beef in every box for a year plus
20 off your first order I mean butcher
box is giving that special deal right
now that is all you have to do is
butcherbox.com hey babe use the code hey
babe ground beef for a year that's plus
20 off your first order two pounds of
ground beef free in every box for a year
plus the 20 bucks I don't know why I
don't know why you're not doing it do it
right now yeah what's wrong with you
yeah hey babe
only dates I have available right now
only place that has tickets left
September 23rd Hulu Theater Madison
Square Garden everything else is sold
out if you want to see my new hour of
stand up Hulu theater September 23rd New
York City Madison Square Garden it's
going to be a great show it's going to
be fun we got a lot of surprise guests
coming in it's going to be awesome and
also there's a lot of fun at patreon.com
christycomedy I'm going to start doing a
new show over there where you get your
steps in with me so it's called getting
your steps in with Chrissy so if you
want her into physical fitness and you
want to get your steps and get motivated
go over to patreon.com christycomedy and
I'm going to be your little box in the
treadmill it's going to be me so you get
get fit with me
what's up guys we got some dates in May
June and July to round out the
Impractical Jokers tour and then more
dates will be announced if you didn't
see it so far all the tickets are on
impractical jokerslive.com these shows
have been fun and outrageous we've had
surprises at them May 19th 20th and 21st
May 19th Arlington Texas College Park
Center May 20th at the Moody Center in
Austin uh May 21st at the Smart
Financial Center in Sugarland moving to
June Columbus June 2nd Cleveland Ohio
June 3rd and Detroit theater Fox uh the
Fox Theater in Detroit on June 4th oh
man this is gonna be fun seanstein
center in the rocket mortgage field
house that's that's those are big shows
June
um Minneapolis Des Moines and Kansas
City June 15 16th and 17th and then we
round out July here in Nashville at the
Opry on the 27th Cambridge Field House
in Indianapolis on July 28th and the
stifle theater two at two shows there in
St Louis on the 29th everything is
available at impractical jokerslive.com
and I will shortly be announcing
a second leg of my solo tour that starts
in July and will run through November so
stay tuned for that when is this coming
out pimpy
this Thursday okay so it's after may 10.
buy some merch check out our merch store
and check out salvocano comedy.com for
updates the turbinates what they are is
a little organ inside your face that you
got possibly resected in order to fix
your deviated symptom turbinates what
they do is when we're breathing in air
right now what the turbine it what that
organs uh uh what it does is it's
basically telling your brain that you're
getting enough oxygen and it's measuring
and saying you are at 100 oxygen brains
him good we're breathing if they resect
if the doctor accidentally resects too
much of the turbulent
resects like takes away a lot of times
resect resect resetting determinant you
got to push both buttons on the side of
the turbine and then this is a factory
that's what it is so what happens is
with the turbine is a lot of times
they're very big and it causes deviated
or if you uh in addition to be
Decepticons is breathing problems cause
sleep apnea whatever so they'll take
away some of the turbine now 99.5 five
percent of the time you deal with Ashley
it corrects the problem you're good to
go your life changes but if you are that
point five percent
if you were that point five percent of
people who get empty nose syndrome where
the turbulent was taken too much of the
turbine it was taken away then what
happens is when you are breathing in air
your brain does not get the signal
because
breathing because the turbinate has been
resected too much
the brain thinks you are 24 hours a day
suffocating and getting no oxygen when
you are breathing in adequate oxygen is
that is that an emergency situation
exactly right there is no cure and it
has got a 98
suicide rate within two years of getting
empty note syndrome and you took that
chance I did I did and I'm brave yes I'm
very brave yes look at this syndrome
willed strong-minded young lady if I
would have known about that I might not
have gotten that sir out of me
because I'll tell you what happened I
was scheduled to get a deviated I was
going to say why and then I was sitting
at the Comedy Cellar saying that oh I
got to go get the surgery the next day
and I was telling someone next to me one
of the managers at the comedy club next
to me about it and then Jim Norton was
eating uh pretzels with mustard and he
goes delicious you better be careful
about empty nose syndrome and I said
what are you talking about and then he
said Google it and he walked away and I
Googled it and I canceled the surgery
immediately because I'm not taking that
risk it is considered rare because most
I don't know point five percent
was like when the snot goes off to
college
Google empty nose syndrome it's got a 90
suicide rate no I believe that so what
are you doing you're just gasping all
the time most people think they said
they they the interview that I want I
can't fix it the day is right now there
is no cure the interview that I watched
said that what the guy explained was he
said do you know when you're at the
bottom of a pool and you have to swim up
quick to get air and it's all you got to
do is get your face above that and then
you can he goes That's what I feel like
all day every day and I just have to I
always feel like I'm at the bottom of
the pool racing to get to the top oh
that sounds horrible they can't just
shut off that nerve nope nope
I guess the point is is that the nerve
is shut off and that's what the brain
does Megan Kelly reported on it you know
it's real
that is truly terrifying I'm thinking
Kelly an alumnus it's like you're
getting um I'm not gonna do it again
Bethlehem High School uh Upstate New
York just learned that yesterday
I actually this is gonna sound I just
met a young person who on their Bucket
List was to come see me live because
they have this incurable disease and so
they're gonna at the end of the year the
end of next year they're going to organs
they're gonna take their life with
dignity can they do that in Oregon
they're going to Oregon where it's legal
you can go to Oregon and you can you can
die with dignity in in order is it legal
there yeah yeah it's legal there I
actually think it's it
so good like I think everyone because
who the [__] wants to be alive at like
98 right you're just falling apart and
if we made it normal it could be such a
nice thing like it could be so nice that
people could get together with their
relatives and like have a really like
the Doug Stanhope joke I don't know if
you guys know
um do I have the name right oh I'm
kidding I was like am I like no we love
doctor I thought I was having a stroke I
was like you guys could be empty no
syndrome come on come on here actually
yeah please Doug if you're listening and
we know that you want you know you are
you know next time he's in here we'll
have him on um you believe in assisted
suicide yeah I I'm on the fence I think
some I don't know I don't know because
you just Nev like you say 90 day who
once lives in 98 but then Kane Tanaka
would have been alive another 18 years
so but he got in trouble working right
he was like the John Stockton doctor
working on assists yes for death assists
yeah he was yes he was and and and he um
he did get in trouble because because I
guess
he killed too many people why did he get
in trouble because wasn't he pulling
plugs but but wasn't he getting their
permission yeah it's it's of course it's
like you have to look at it on a
case-by-case basis but look at like the
some like the opioid crisis you wouldn't
say people don't need painkillers it
just has to be like regulated in a
thoughtful way and like of course like
terrible people are going to do terrible
things but I I just think like I don't
know man like if I
if I had empty nose syndrome it sucks
I'd want the option to not have it be a
mess when I off myself yeah right you
know you want you can't fill your nose I
think the issue becomes that then if you
legalize it and do that then you might
start to get people who will
want to euthanize themselves because
they got a paper cut you'll get people
who get they'll get too dramatic with it
so there needs to be steps but aren't
those people gonna aren't they gonna do
it anyway
We're Not Gonna Save every suicide is
what we're saying here yeah well don't
they do
it or lens or something
or something Switzerland maybe whatever
happened don't let people that have a
flare for drama be eligible yeah save
the drama and the trauma for your mom
for your mother it's big in Canada they
actually prescribe it there and they're
having like a issue with people with
depression requesting prescriptions for
suicide right maybe maybe depression
maybe it has to be look I don't
I don't want to get in trouble but maybe
it has to be some because I'm not a
doctor but maybe it has to be some sort
of physical the way that
when you put your dog down it's because
it's not feeding itself and it can't go
to the bathroom right right why don't we
use the same criteria right if you not
to equate us to dogs right but like if I
can't go to the bathroom and I can't eat
yeah maybe maybe it's like uh like uh or
if you keep or if you like yeah you
can't go to the bathroom yeah like you
wet the bed like yeah the kid wants to
bed two three times you know he said do
you want to get euthanized you better
yeah I mean that's what it's going to
come down to I can't have this when
they're that young they spell it
y-o-u-t-h-a yes yes yes
um but I think it's it's it is it is it
is an interesting it is an interesting
concept
um in society like what's okay and
what's not okay because you know listen
we're out of time now where everything
almost everything is okay almost you can
do you can do whatever you want a lot of
times you can get away with it and I
don't know I feel like it could be the
Glory Days or it could be the end of the
Empire we don't know but the goal on hey
babe is to figure it out yeah I think
it's the end of the Empire you think
it's the end of the Empire I think
social media has made it the end of the
Empire that's my thing climate change is
social media but we're not talking about
next year the end of the Empire could
take 100 years
it's all this is all coming I think AI
will save us if we can all have all of
our jobs replaced if AI can move at the
speed where we can all be replaced by an
AI and we can just sit around at home
and relax that would be good
it's going to take out the working class
first and then you know but it should
take out the politicians that's what I
think robot politicians wow robot
politicians chat GPT for president uh
because they're gonna make unbiased
decisions
I'll be a robot yeah but according to
the article I read it it depends on how
that AI is programmed of course of
course right who's programming it of
course Tim did you see the Dr Kevorkian
that you just head up there check this
out nickname Dr Death Murad Jacob Jack
Kevorkian you you that first name Murad
you switch to DNA it's murder yes that's
a very evil sounding name yeah that's
crazy yeah I just noticed it right now
now when do you shop
um because you you appeared you hey yo
here with new items yet I've never known
you to carve out time for shopping I've
never heard you say I went shopping
today on the road I mean we've gone
shopping a couple times but I don't see
you as someone who's like I'm gonna go
get these baby blues and uh and then so
when does this happen is it online is it
impulse buying uh do you set out and say
this is gonna be part of my glow up
today I'm going shopping from X to X how
do you attain your new new uh here's
what happened with me yeah I was on the
Ithaca Commons
no Ithaca Commons is a street in Ithaca
like one of those like walking areas
where there's no cars Ithaca Commons
right by the State Theater and Ithaca
shout out they had a picture of Hassan
by my green room
Ithaca Commons I went into a store it
weed is legal up there I went into a
store
that and uh um the great Mike Cannon was
with me he was going there to buy
Edibles and other other marijuana
paraphernalia mine came it was great it
was great Mike came with me we had a
great time
and I bought these Oreo cookies from
Japan for the kids mint strawberry they
get down like that with the kitkats I
love it yeah
or uh Oreo uh cookies from Japan
come outside
walk right past the sneaker store and I
was looking at the light that one of
them came in a light blue one of the
Oreo cookies in Japan came in like a
lightish blue box and I had them and I
was going to show my daughter on
FaceTime and then I saw these in the
window of the store next to me and for
some reason it felt like a sign it was a
sign it felt like you if you really want
to be cool you're gonna match your
sneakers with the Oreo box and I went in
there and I said if these are under 100
I said if these are under 100 I will buy
them they were 99 size 79. I said to the
guy I swear I go to the guy I go do you
have these in a size 12. he goes yes I
go if they are under 100
I will buy them if they are over 100 I
will not buy them I said how much are
they and he said 99.99 no way I swear
but were they or was he they were 89.95
okay but with tax they came about 97 but
I gave him a hundred dollar bill and I
how kind huh how kind how kind and they
I gotta tell you something these are
some of the most comfortable sneakers
I've had yeah Blazers are nice yeah I
will just let them know who's watching
I've got a pair not all Blazers are
comfortable these are you're looking at
and those white ones we got the white
with the black those are comfortable I
love those but I have a I have like four
or five other pairs that I almost can't
wear because they're so narrow right oh
I have very narrow feet yeah yeah um I
have wide set feet that's why I don't
understand how you feeling comfortable I
don't know these are just comfortable a
lot of times like I said you know like
you said sometimes sneakers aren't
comfortable like my Stan Smith Adidas
not comfortable my hammer toes rub on
the top of them some shoes are fit for
hammer toe some shoes aren't yeah it's
the toe box you need a wide toe box my
toe in a box
listen weird because with the rider
strike we're gonna write SNL we're gonna
do it this weekend that's so great
that's good yeah oh yeah what are they
doing a two-man SNL team I think that
that would make it better
yeah well no writing no well no I don't
know if it's done for this year but
however long the rider strike is I guess
yes you're right yeah it's done for the
year because they would be awesome PDD
was supposed to host it
oh no [__] yeah
what can you wait so they already had
the finale
I think they didn't know that it was
going to do the finale but if there's
going to be a writer strike and it's
already may they take the summer off
anyway
no Jimmy Kimmel foul and they're all
stopped back in the day in 2005. back in
the day when I was young I'm not a kid
anymore but some days I still wish I was
a kid again
um I I think that they are all on Hiatus
as we say in America oh okay
Hiatus because they ain't us Hiatus
cause they ain't us speaking of good
shows guess what's coming out season
three you just let me know our favorite
schedule of all time on Netflix I think
you should leave by the great comedy
genius Tim Robinson I did not know that
season three there it is babes and I am
so excited today let's watch it together
let's watch it seriously no let's watch
it no I'm being dead serious I promise
we should be like alive yes yes yes we
should do a live watch along this this
is the one where you watch every episode
they're like 19 minutes yeah yeah it's
so hard to turn them off he's you're in
a net you're in the next one it's not
funny it's hard to turn me off when I'm
watching it yeah
wait the first sketch of last year
season two when he's opening up the door
the wrong way or was that season one
that's the first I mean and last year
was the first sketch with corn cop TV
hot dog no yeah
I want to like I'm so tired I want to
ask him what his process is because it's
unlike any other it negates every rule
you've ever learned about any writing
about improv I don't know who it was it
might have been Che might not don't
quote me if it was Mike J was somebody a
friend of ours from who works at SNL and
I asked them about it maybe it was Sam J
I'm not sure but one of the friends said
that Tim Robinson always would have
those sketches when he was a writer at
SNL but they were so off the wall yeah
no one wouldn't make it but that his
brain was like designed for you go back
and watched a few of them that he was in
some of them are that that wild and
they're really funny too right but they
didn't utilize him the right way imagine
you let someone like him go and you
don't get what he's doing now yeah like
he could have been this he could have
been doing these as sketches on SNL man
and it would have made SNL even better I
mean because so not everybody loves it
but that's what you want in your art
that's true everybody that's true you
don't want that that's not a good thing
everybody loves it you know uh I'm safe
then so I I showed it I got so dudes
when it first came out and I was at
myself I was up on a little vacation
with friends and I had another cut my
manager and uh his wife and we were all
hanging out of there and we that night
with Drake and smoking a little whatever
I said you don't understand me and Q
were like you know what I'm saying you
gotta watch your show you will we're
gonna cry laughing right that was at the
point where I was showing people I would
just show people and watch the whole
season with like 10 different people
because I I love showing it to people
yeah it's that good and I we sat down
into watching it we were at his house
for the weekend and he did not get it at
all no and we watched like three or four
episodes and like women killed like like
laughing and look at him and he's just
like yeah I just don't get it I will say
it took me one or two to get into to
like understand because as a writer your
your brain is programmed to look at a
sketch and be like three beats the
Titans don't say no but like I just was
he an improviser because I imagine him
as an improviser and I'm sure he was
yeah oh yeah like he must have been
almost horrible to do in problem with
because he's always screaming at the
scene is always just being like yeah no
no like it's that's always like yeah the
weird thing I love it though that he
hasn't put himself in everything and he
casts like I know and you can always
tell which
him holding himself as a baby
but you could tell even when he's not in
the sketches which one should have been
his character or that he yes exactly
exactly and it's like kind of cool
because I could imagine him doing doing
it if he was in it but it is like kind
of cool refreshing to see someone else
yeah this is the strongest boy the
strongest boy pageant or whatever like
that with the host oh my God yeah funny
that I I and our boy Paul that's Sam
Richardson right Sam Richardson is also
great
um yeah uh oh okay what time is it it's
game time game time I actually use Game
Time recently no because I got ticks the
app yeah I got Yankee tickets and what I
love about game time here's what they do
not only is it a very user-friendly app
to go buy tickets they show you exactly
where you're sitting they make it so
easy whatever what they do is because
they get these sick killer deals on last
minute tickets and they have the best
price guarantee this is what separates
them their best price guarantee
you can buy tickets and then if and then
if you can prove that you paid more on
another site and and they didn't get it
then what they do is they give you 110.
your money plus 110 back that's how
that's how confident they are game time
guarantee means you'll always get the
best price if you find tickets in the
same section and row for Less game time
will credit you 110 of the difference
it's unbelievable once you get the
images of the seats is event
cancellation protection they have last
minute Flash Deals uh if you forget
planning months in advance you don't
don't even worry about it don't matter
you could get every every event you want
to go to last minute deals with game
time uh download the game time app
create an account yes use code hey babe
yes 20 off your first purchase so terms
applied but again create an account
redeem code hey babe 20 off download
game time today last minute tickets
lowest price guaranteed
so all y'all need to know that's all you
all need to know all right listen this
episode sponsored by Bluetooth so you
know what time it is time to talk about
sex Let's Talk About Sex crazy let's
talk about you and me let's talk about
all the good things and the bad things
that can be let's talk about hey baby oh
let's talk about Bluetooth
um same ingredients you want to bring
the heat in the bedroom yes I do now you
can increase your performance and get
that extra confidence in bed listen up
bluetooth.com the process is simple sign
up at bluetooth.com consult with one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you receive
prescription within days it's got the
same active ingredients as Viagra Cialis
and Levitra but in chewable tablets and
a fraction of the cost the best part
it's done online no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward combos no
waiting online you just get an erection
and it's gorgeous and you can take them
anytime day or night so yes you can plan
ahead it'll be ready when the
opportunity arises absolutely baby
absolutely the confidence where it
counts blue chew wants to help you have
better sex discover the options at
bluetooth.com chew it and do it we've
got a special deal for our listeners try
blue chew for free made in the USA made
in the USA that didn't ship directly in
discreet packaging which I love
blue chew for free all you have to do is
use the promo code hey babe at checkout
and pay the five dollar shipping that's
it bluetooth.com promo code hey babe get
your first month free bluetooth.com for
details and important safety information
and we thank Bluetooth for sponsoring
the podcast
you ever beat anybody up Ashley or get
into a fist fight no the closest I had
to that was
um I
I was playing like kickball or something
um not in Shadow just kind of like pick
up as a kid yeah not as an adult not as
an adult because it is just it is
because playing kickball is an adult is
a very lesbian thing to do yes I would
say that's super gay to be in a sports
League a severely injured as an adult
playing kickball you really can if you
miss you could pull a hand especially
with flat feet and hammer toes the three
of us should not be doing this that's
true or narrow feet two kickball though
because it's like in between other balls
Sports what do you mean it doesn't get
its shine basketball baseball
yeah kickball I would love to see a
professional kickball yeah that would be
sick so what happened kickers there do
their their moment in the sun yeah
um so you're playing kickball
um what happens I'm I'm at second base
or something talking to another kid I
was like oh I like your shirt and then I
I accidentally invaded someone's
personal bubble for the first time my
bad I looked at the tag she was like
what the [__] are you doing
we came from different worlds
I didn't know that if you looked at
someone's tag they might say this was I
was like eight I did not where was the
tag on the shirt it was sticking out
okay now I just kind of touched it and
looked at it my bad this is secondary
talk in the middle of an active game
yeah yeah I was like but you know we're
kids we're just kidding sure and then I
start I guess I was running the bases
because I started to run and then she
was like well I'm gonna grab your tag
and she grabbed me by the collar of my
shirt and I didn't fight back I just
fully went down and was like I'm sorry I
invaded your personal bubble this is the
problem this is the problem with youth
sports though what is this kind of you
know talking about tags and then getting
into it fighting about teams on second
base yeah you can't have it we're
supposed to game down yeah it does I was
part and fully my fault fully my fault I
apologize and I never invaded someone's
personal bubble again but do you think
that do you want to go do you really
want to be that person that goes to your
whole life without punching someone
crazy yeah I don't I don't want to punch
anyone I just got to do it sometimes you
fantasize about punching somebody but in
reality I really don't want it I don't
know when I say anyone I don't mean stop
I am I can't fantasize about punching
someone because I'm worried about
hurting my own hand yeah right I
literally even in the fantasy I'm like
I'm gonna have is this gonna swell and
I'm gonna have to ice this is the Jewish
quarter yeah the happiest person in this
room is homeless pimp and he gets jumped
once a month
well I mean I'm almost almost got jumped
in Staten Island on my way to the Pod
yeah yeah him gets jumped is it because
of the way that you are like something I
wouldn't mess with Tim he's a big guy
just think I'm born in New York and New
York has me tagged for a couple
instances a year see I think no one
messes with me because I am born in New
York I think because you know when you
go to Times Square there are people like
oh my God everyone's getting mugged in
Times Square I walk through Times Square
all the time for shows and stuff like
that yeah what Caroline's has closed now
but like back I know no one ever even
looks actually don't tempt fate
I think people see you as a mellow
fellow I didn't even mean to rhyme that
but so be it sometimes tragic magic
happens
um and that's the name of this episode
mellow Fellowship
I think you look very very chill and
relaxed and I think maybe maybe uh you
give off that Vibe and then people are
like Well he seems like a peaceful
entity I usually get to talk my way out
of it yeah like when's the last time you
actually got hit
um and yeah I mean last year those kids
said my shoes would look better on them
and kind of followed me for a couple
minutes but they didn't hit you no but
they just they would have yeah that's
why I carry a loud whistle
do you really no no but I should you
should I actually don't I swear to God I
just saw one uh that was like an 80
decibel whistle I was gonna buy that's
it everyone is away from you yeah I'm
just gonna because why not have a
whistle that's 80 decibels no I think
you don't I don't think they run but
whistle yourself also though you call
attention to yeah to the situation and
for 19.99 throw it on the keychain or
whatever it may be 999. this is a price
point for safety you can't put a price
tag on safety yeah easy
I like that I got pepper spray that
scares me keys in the fingers is a big
one yeah that well that's [__]
[__] stupid yeah cause now everyone's
got a key fob I was gonna take like an
introductory like crosstalk class just
to learn how to just you know just maybe
one little trouble let me tell you
something no it's funny you mentioned
that let me tell you something let me
make a let me make a a PSA right here
and I don't know what I haven't mastered
it yet but I have been secretly and I
want to tell anyone I was just wanted to
kind of show it but now that the cat's
out of the bag I've been working with
Krav Maga with a Krav Maga specialist
because here's the thing you know craft
who is gonna try and take you down on
the street Ash you'd be surprised yes
yes you'd be surprised a thousand
dollars glasses right there yep I guess
people at no fashion and are you know
seedy yeah I'll take them down they'll
take them down so you so you so so crap
Maga by the way craft Maga right craft
manga which I know it that is the
official name but we've the God will
take the stank off it but Krav Maga AKA
Krav Maga if it and I get it it's a
capitalist Society I'm an American I
believe in capitalism go make your money
girl whatever you need to do but if
you're taking a Krav Maga class and
they're extending it and there's a belt
system and it's over six months and five
years that's not what Krav Maga is you
can do it and you will learn it and
whatever the real crowd from a God the
real win that's what I want two weeks
that is how the Israelis learn it that
is the Israeli fighting system of
because and then you're versed because
here's the thing reason being is
oh here we go
reason being is is because Israel is a
country that's surrounded by its enemies
everywhere they go they're in the Middle
East they're surrounded by the enemies
only Jewish country everybody doesn't
like them whatever
they only they candidates would come in
or the people that got drafted you know
you have to join the military at 18
would come in right typically at times
of War would come in and only have two
Max three weeks before they're deployed
into the battlefield so rather than but
they're doing it 40 hours a week right
but well yes and no no I'll take down
two I'll take my two weeks vacay two
weeks I could come back a self-defense
killing machine easily because what
happens is with Krav Maga it's it's one
of like Jiu Jitsu and karate yeah it is
a martial art right it is a martial art
there's an art to it you can't learn art
like that Krav Maga is simply survival
so Krav Maga cuts the fat the real craft
my God that you can learn two weeks
rather than me learning the proper chop
and the choke Holden and the delicacy of
it it is just simply you have two weeks
he I'm gonna show you right now how to
take someone down and kill them and
anyone can do it and that's what it is
but again I'm taking it you really what
you're really learning is in almost a
spiritual thing yes because everything
it's twisting nuts it's grabbing throats
it's gouging eyes it's fighting it is
not it is not anything like oh let me
yeah it's it's just let me disarm this
and get your nuts kill or be killed
actually crab Maga means get the nuts
it's doing all the things that are that
like you're not supposed to do
that's all it is disarm someone
else this is part of it all right now
because you're enrolled in this you're
doing it in two weeks did you come from
Krav Maga this morning and you're going
back to Krav Maga after this no today I
actually did a spin class okay
that's what I do that's my mental that's
my mental fortitude I get on the bike
and it's hard I loved I love the [__]
instructors just just being like go
within yourself or whatever I went to a
spin class one time with a couple
friends of mine a couple and I didn't
know what I signed up for I was like
I'll do the spin class they turn the
lights off just start screaming at you
and I was like the one that couldn't
keep up yeah it was crazy by the way
what I've been doing a little bit is
taking Hot Yoga I've been taking Hot
Yoga yeah ready for this is that Vinyasa
is that what that is no I don't know
what the hell it is it's just yoga in
2000 degree rooms it's on new door plane
it's a cold something hot yoga it's
called Hot Yoga so I was taking it and
it was one of the classes I went to
there was there was like 75 people in a
room that only holds like 50. like they
just crammed them in that's how they get
hot right so we had no space so we're
coming to the end of the class and we're
all doing our positions this way where
I'm Dr you are dripping in sweat like
it's insane the for the final move the
instructor asked us to all turn our
bodies around and face the opposite way
and as I was turning around the bottom
of my foot scraped against the girl's
arm next to me just a sweaty disgusting
foot just went all over my foot just
went all over her arm and I was like I
am so sorry and she said an apology
won't do anything she was like that's
the most disgusting thing that's ever
happening I was like yeah but you're not
mad at me right and she was like no she
was like but that is like really gross
and I was like what do you want me to do
I have I'm like a bigger guy I swear to
God she's like what
is that the one where like if someone
points a gun at me I like take my hoodie
off
100 and then I had the gun in my hand
all of a sudden 100 okay and they teach
that in one week they'll teach you that
in two weeks you'll get the hoodie throw
two weeks and then you walk out of that
confident that if in real life someone
pulls that gun you're gonna rip off your
t-shirt do some magic and you're gonna
have the gun 100 so there's no literally
you don't hesitate that I could save you
the time even for the two weeks if
you're ever in a in a fight all you have
to do is grab genitals you are aiming
for men and women's genitals I learned
that as a kid all the time
grabbing [__] grabbing balls what will
that do it's hard they have a lot of
pain points in the vagina
yeah but it's not like tentacles though
like you have a gun and someone grabs
your I don't think it's like testicles
but if you if
you had the dexterity to grab one of my
labs
if you had that point
yeah
but that that's pretty much what it's
doing I mean they'll you they'll you get
somebody turned around you stick your
knuckle in their [__] this is not
about sparring it's about going for the
kill
sparring admit you know with other
markets you're going to disarm them and
you're looking to murder them
immediately that's what it is I have a
question so in the class though I'm
interested in that I don't care about
the art of it yeah yes though in the
class though how do you practice
grabbing someone's balls you put cups on
and you put pads on and if you ever went
full speed with me yet but I'd be just
doing one-on-one and he's grabbing you
your balls he'll get me and then he'll
have the hand right there and be like
you know
obviously you know what to do you would
yeah you would squeeze and twist right
that's all it is squeeze and twist he
said if you get Jesus Christ if you get
anyone in a situation that has a gun or
a weapon if you squeeze and twist their
testicles they are going to drop their
weapon and run away
[Laughter]
that actually I actually think if you
just the no pun intended ballsiness of
going for an attacker's balls like if
someone's attacking you and then you
just go straight for their balls or
something psychologically yeah like over
this person you know when you fight a
bear yeah and you're supposed to do this
the Bear's like oh this person this
person means business I think when you
go for the balls they're like oh this
person which was very interesting and
I'm very happy she did this she was on
the train
um in the morning but it was like not a
crowded train and there was a guy like
harassing passengers and my mom got very
nervous and she she had a uh drinks
black coffee had a large cup of black
coffee that she had just bought in the
Subway and then threw the Black Coffee
in the guy's face all did his face yeah
and he was like like on like on the
floor like rivaling in pain and my mom
got off the stop she threw Black Coffee
in the guy's face that's just what you
should do that's so [__] badass and
my mom said she was like every time she
gets on a train everything she always
has hot black coffee no way as a weapon
not a drink yeah
you should do that women always have hot
black coffee or hot black tea if you're
trying to get away from the caffeine
yeah but you know and then use it as a
weapon if you don't want to drink it
yeah they teach you that in Krav Maga
they don't know that's what it is yeah
it has to be humiliating though if
someone is is jumping you or beating you
up and you're in a fight and you keep
trying to grab their bowls and you can't
get it and they're just slapping you and
just keep reaching but like you get
slapped and you then you run at him
again and every time you're just going
for the balls and you and it looks just
like it doesn't look like you're trying
to fight no it just looks like it just
that's humiliating yeah but if find a
flight if you got to grab the balls grab
the balls yeah that's what it is what I
agree yeah actually where can people see
you speaking of balls oh yeah I have a
special out on YouTube it's uh free so
go watch it please what's it called uh
it's just Ashley Gavin live in Chicago
okay nice g-a-v-i-n yeah it's just a
classic comedy special and this is your
schedule right here that's my schedule
yeah wow look at this you got your go
you're all over the place
I'm very proud I'll be vulnerable and
it's all the good cities yeah so we're
doing my first theater tour so please
come nice August 24th 26 you'll be in
Sacramento 26 is my birthday if you want
to let the ground know oh yeah I'll say
yeah how much Krav Maga are you guys
doing because kravika oh my God Master
christmas.com
everything's list Ed there my name is
Ashley Gavin I mean you got dates on
dates girls I'm doing okay good
yeah Ashley if you just search Ashley
Gavin all of us will come up some are
designated all ages some are 18 plus
summer 19 plus and we don't know why but
that's just absolutely I had to a lot of
my fans are kind of younger so I've had
to really fight for the 18 plus and the
19 plus and stuff like that so okay so
that these guys could come there it is
but you can come beautiful uh what was
it gonna say I don't remember oh and
Chris you've done my podcast we're
having gay sex yes and you are welcome
anytime absolutely it was a great
podcast we're having gay sex yeah which
is awesome don't knock it till you try
it I'll do it yeah it's actually a
requirement that you have gay sex right
before we have a guy when I have men on
we have a guy standing by to [__] you
yeah yeah and so you have a story just
in case you don't have anything right
yeah well we'll always meet him that day
I have stories yeah yeah we got stories
and we have and we also have proof
Sal's all over the road everywhere merch
get our merch get the merch we got all
great merch and uh the only tickets I
have left are September 23rd at the Hulu
theater in Madison Square Garden and
that's it everything is incredible what
you you sold the stadium man like
between Radio City and the Hulu theater
you did a stadium that's incredible
meaning a minor league Stadium next stop
babe next stop maybe next stop no it's
gonna happen you'll do that
you will you're going to do it I
appreciate it no question well I
appreciate it so much and um we love you
guys and you know we're here every
Thursday at 11 A.M tell us what you want
us to talk about and we'll probably
won't check the emails and we'll just
continue doing what we want to do but we
do appreciate your support and love
thank you thanks to sign up for the
patreon thank you
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey
[Music]